the traffic in New York is way worse now
dude everything in New York is gonna be
either a hotel or a Duane Reade and
maybe like there'll be some pizza shops
but it'll everything will be a chain
like nobody no who the [__] lives in New
York anymore
they're just [__] Duane Reade after
Dwayne Reed Starbucks after Dwayne Reed
and then like you can go see Aladdin and
the Lion King
I get it dude it's you know and there's
still those die hard yeah but nah you
just don't know where to go uh
well how about how five years ago you
just stepped outside and everything was
a [__] party
five years ago you could stay at 33rd
and [__] and walk out and still have
a great time and now dude everything is
a Duane read it just sucks people always
talk about New York his hot take New
York I haven't been in New York since
before the pandemic 80 of the
restaurants now close at like midnight
it used to be 24 hours you gotta like
travel far
if you want to get some at 1am or 2 A.M
it sucks all right now I'm Mr New York
now I believe New York right now my soul
rests easy in New York right like when
I'm in L.A a piece of me is missing
and it's a piece of you know it's my my
soul is in New York right and we all
know that I am New York so
so
I
you can't get food late at night unless
you go far right unless you live next to
one of these spots now people are in the
comments crying you you did you should
have went they should have went to this
or that or the Stardust Diner whatever
the [__] you know all right so
how about this
living in New York I cannot imagine
living in New York your whole life that
would suck donkey balls now here's
that's the hot take the hot take and
here's why people say la in traffic is
the worst thing in the world dude
at least in La you have to drive to get
to the traffic
okay in La you're at least at your house
and then you drive a few blocks and then
you go ah [__] this LA traffic
in New York
you walk out your door and there's
traffic
already by the way on the sidewalk
you get your oh oh and you get to the
car baby you're sitting got there's a
guy pulling out
goddamn [__] [__] god [__] ass [__]
that goddamn [__]
someone hits the roof and the other guy
hey they don't care no one cares then we
get shot you know
it's so annoying dude the traffic in New
York [__] sucks this is what you say
and you're gonna be like yo um so uh how
far away is it and they they this is
always the answer in New York it's only
like six blocks but it takes 25 minutes
really because of traffic yeah and also
you got to turn around and do the
[__] thing and it's a one-way Street
oh dude blow me New York it's not it
anymore you know what's it Brooklyn but
then you go to Brooklyn you see all the
people with the twisty mustaches you go
wipe my [__] dude get out of here man
no
so there's no place to live it's either
hipster City or traffic central and that
sucks so that's what's up and that sucks
[Music]